GOOD AFTERNOON WELCOME BACK
SUBCOMMITTEE FORESTED
ADMINISTRATION WE HAVE ONE ISSUE
IN THE GYM TODAY. DISCUSSING
HOMELESSNESS A ROLL CALL THE
ESTABLISH A FORM PLEASE.
COOPER HERE CABALLERO. CHIU HERE
CHOI HIGH OBERNOLTE.
WE THIRTEEN ON THE VOTE ONLY
CALENDAR RIPOLL ONE ITEM AND
THAT'S ISSUE NUMBER TEN. AND
WILL ADDRESS THAT AFTER THE MAY
REVISE SO FIVE PREV MOTION FOR
ITEMS.
.
ONE THROUGH THIRTEEN EXCLUDING
ITEM NUMBER TEN.
I GOT A FIRST AND SECOND ROLL
CALL PLEASE COOPER AYE HOW MY
ARROW.
CHIU. CHOI AYE OBERNOLTE.
THE MOTION PASSES.
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER ONE HAD
PART OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT. HOMELESSNESS.
SO RESTORED OFF WITH.
BUDGET CHAIR TEAM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IT'S
HONOR TO BE HERE AND NOW. BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE FOUR TO TALK ABOUT
ONE OF THE MOST PRESSING ISSUES.
IN OUR STATE ON HOMELESSNESS
USED TO BE A. ISSUE THAT WAS
PRIMARILY LEFT FOR URBAN
CALIFORNIA NOW WE'RE SEEING IT
IN SUBURBAN AND RURAL
CALIFORNIA.
PROBABLY HAPPENING EVERYWHERE ON
ANY GIVEN NIGHT WE CAN HAVE OVER
A HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
HOMELESS PEOPLE ON OUR STREETS.
WHICH IS JUST ABSOLUTELY
UNACCEPTABLE WORKS TOWARD NEARLY
PROUD THAT OUR STATE JUST BECAME
THE WORLD'S FIFTH LARGEST
ECONOMY.
BUT WHAT'S THE POINT OF BEING
THE FIFTH LARGEST COMIC WE CAN'T
HOUSE EVERY SINGLE CALIFORNIA.
SO TODAY.
WE BRING FORWARD A PROPOSAL ON
THE BACKS OF FIVE MUCH OF THE
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE ON HOUSING
IN TERMS OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT IN. AFFORDABLE
HOUSING INCENTIVES WHICH I THINK
ARE OBSOLETE CRITICAL IS JUST A
HOP ALSO TO FOCUS ON PRIMARILY.
A RAPIDLY HOUSING EMERGENCY
RESPONSES SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
VERY MUCH TRYING TO GET PEOPLE
OFF THE STREET INTO THE MEDIA
SHELTERS OF THIS PROPOSAL WAS
CRAFTED.
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE ELEVEN
LARGE CITY MAYORS OF BUT IT IS
FUND IS IT IS A ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR BUDGET REQUEST
THAT ANY CITY. ANY CITY CAN
REQUEST AND GET FUNDING FOR AND
IT'S A MATCHING PROGRAM SO THAT
CITIES WOULD GET THEIR FUNDING
MATCHED
BASED ON A WHAT THEY WANT TO
EXPAND AND JUST TO GIVE YOU A
COUPLE IDEAS OF WHAT IS.
HOW WOULD OUR POTENTIAL
EXPENDITURES IT COULD BE
SHELTERED DIVERSION RAPID RE
HOUSING RENTAL ASSISTANCE?
EMERGENCY SHELTER NAVIGATION
CENTERS BRIDGE HOUSING AND
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
ARM AS YOU ALL KNOW CITIES ON
THE FRONT LINES THE SEE THIS
POPULATION EVERY DAY.
THE POPULATION NO LONGER IS
JUST.
SEEN AT THE POPULATION THE
PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO LOOK AT
THESE IS NOW A PUBLIC HEALTH
HAZARD WE SAW A HEPATITIS
OUTBREAK IN SAN DIEGO. IT IS NOW
A PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE.
BECAUSE WE ARE SEEING THIS.
POPULATION GROW ENDED IN
PARTICULAR IS FRANKLY IT'S IT'S
AN ISSUE OF HUMANITY WHETHER WE
CAN'T ACCEPT OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE ON OUR STREETS
EVERY NIGHT THE SAME TIME. THAT
WE HAVE.
.
THE LARGEST ECONOMY OF ANY STATE
IN THE COUNTRY SO. WITHOUT I
APOLOGIZE BECAUSE I CANNOT STAY
THROUGH ALL THE DELIBERATIONS
BUT WE HAVE OUR TWO EXPERTS IN
ONE. ON ONE FORMER ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND SENATOR WHO WAS ON
HIS WAY.
MAKING A.
MAKING AN ENTRANCE AND HE'S
GONNA ANSWER ALL YOUR QUESTIONS
BUT LET ME TURN IT OVER TO
ARMED.
MISA.
BRENDA SHOCKLEY WHO IS THE
DEPUTY MAYOR OF ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT
FOR THE OFFICE OF LOS ANGELES
MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU.
TWO THE COMMITTEE TO THE CHAIR.
ON BEHALF OF MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR GIVING
US THE OPPORTUNITY. TO.
DESCRIBE.
WHY WE HAVE JOINED WITH THE?
ELEVENTH THE BIG ELEVEN MAYORS.
TO SEEK SOME RELIEF FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO ADDRESS
THE CRISIS OF HOMELESSNESS.
AND SOME WAYS IT'S PRETTY OF.
IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT I SHOULD
GO FIRST BECAUSE THE.
CITY AND COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES
REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY ONE HALF OF ALL
HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
CITY HAS.
AND THE COUNTY TOGETHER HAVE.
TAKE AN ENORMOUS STEPS.
IN THE FORM OF UP BOND MEASURE
OF ONE POINT TWO BILLION DOLLARS
FOR.
PERMITTED SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
THAT WILL BE BUILT OVER TEN
YEARS AND IT WOULD BE TEN
THOUSAND UNITS THOUSAND EACH
YEAR.
COUPLED WITH THE QUARTER PERCENT
SALES TAX THAT THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES VOTERS APPROVED.
THAT.
WILL PROVIDE SUPPORT SERVICES.
YEAH. MISTER MAYOR.
SORRY.
IT IS VERY GOOD AND.
YOU IT IS HARD TO KNOW.
I'LL THAT. QUARTER PERCENT SALES
TAX THAT WAS A COMPANION EFFORT
BY THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES TO
PROVIDES UP.
SUPPORTIVE SERVICES TO THOSE WHO
WERE BEING HOUSED.
ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT IN THE CITY
OF LOS ANGELES WHERE WE HAVE
SOME THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
HOMELESS PEOPLE.
EIGHTY PERCENT OFTHOSE PEOPLE
ARE.
LIVING EITHER IN ENCAMPMENTS ON
THE STREET OR IN VEHICLES.
UNDER PASSES INTO THE FREEWAY.
AND.
IT IS FAR BEYOND JUST AN ISSUE
OF QUALITY OF LIFE.
THAT IT REALLY IN THE LAST YEAR.
AND I IN THE COUNTY OF LOS
ANGELES OVER EIGHT HUNDRED.
HOMELESS PEOPLE DIED.
AND THE PRESSURE ON THE.
HOSPITAL AND HEALTH SYSTEM LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
CITY SERVICES IS IS ENORMOUS.
BOB THE CITY HAS TAKEN.
AND AND FOUND WAYS IN THE LAST
TWO YEARS TO.
QUADRUPLE ITS INVESTMENT IN
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS.
BUT IT'S STILL NOT ENOUGH.
IN THE LAST TWO YEARS WE'VE HAD
A THIRTEEN PERCENTAGE CREEK
INCREASE IN HOMELESSNESS AND
LAST YEAR WAS A TWENTY ERCENT
INCREASE. WE WILL KNOW LATER
THIS MONTH AND WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT IT WON'T BE AS HIGH BUT WE
ARE ACCEPTING THAT THERE WILL BE
AGAIN MORE INCREASE.
THE ABILITY TO MEET THESE
CHALLENGES AND TO MEET THIS
CRISIS.
AND IT IS IT'S A CRISES.
WHAT I'VE HEARD WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT THIS IN THE PAST
THAT?
WELL IT'S IT'S NOT AN
EARTHQUAKE IN ITS NOT A FIRE I
IT'S NOT A DISASTER.
BUT I TRULY BEG TO DIFFER AND I
THINK FOR EACH OF YOU AS YOU
MOVE ABOUT.
STEP OVER PEOPLE TO GET WHERE
YOU HAVE TO GO THAT IT'S BECOME
WHERE IT'S IN THE CITY IT.
HAS BECOME AMOST NORMAL BECAUSE
PEOPLE CANNOT SAFELY SLEEP AT
NIGHT THEY SLEEP IN THE DAY IN
THEIR TENTS.
ON THE STREET IN THE BUSINESS TO
OUR.
PARTS OF THE BUSINESS I SEE JEFF
NODDING BECAUSE I KNOW THAT
MARKET ST.
IT'S IT'S NOT UNUSUAL AT ALL TO
HAVE TO GO THROUGH OUR AROUND
THE TENT IN ORDER TO. EVEN
CONDUCT BUSINESS
BUT MORE THAN THAT.
IN AS WAS SAID US.
DATE THAT HAS
NOW THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD.
THERE. IS SUCH A NEED.
AND.
THE RESOURCES
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE IMMEDIATELY.
WE'VE HOUSE THIRTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE OVER TIME
MUCH THERE'S.
.
I COULD GO INTO THE LITANY OF
EFFORTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE AND
I'LL BE HAPPY TO DO SO IF YOU
LIKE. BUT THE POINT IS THAT. NO
ONE
AND NO SYSTEM.
IN THIS STATE.
PREPARED FOR THE PERFECT STORM
THAT CREATES THE INFLOW INTO
HOPELESSNESS.
WHERE YOU HAVE THE
AFFORDABILITY?
PEOPLE WHO WORK EVERYDAY BUT
CANNOT AFFORD TO LIVE. AND I
THINK IN LOS ANGELES NOW A ONE
BEDROOM APARTMENT IS TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH AND THAT
IS NOT HIGH END THAT'S JUST
BEING ABLE TO. LIVE IN A
BUILDING.
THAT.
YOU HAVE IN ADDITION TO THAT THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE.
AS A RESULT OF.
PROP FORTY SEVEN THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE AND THERE WAS A RECENT
STUDY THE NUMBER OF HOMELESS
PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD CONTACT.
WITH THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
IN THIS COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES IS
CLOSE TO SIXTY FIVE.
PERCENT AND AS A RESULT
SO MANY OF THE BARRIERS THAT
PREVENT THEM FROM GETTING
HOUSING AND
CLAIM AT. ALL OF THOSE FOLD INTO
WHY WE NEED FLEXIBLE DOLLARS TO
ADDRESS PREVENTION.
WE NEED FLEXIBLE DOLLARS TO BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT.
IN ADDITION TO BUILDING HOUSING
LOOKING AT EXISTING STRUCTURES
AND BEING ABLE TO MOVE QUICKLY
TO RENOVATE TO NOT HAVE IT BE A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS A UNIT IN
THREE TO FIVE YEARS DOWN THE
LINE. BUT TO REALLY MOVE PEOPLE.
OFF THE STREETS.
I UNDERSTAND AND I TOTALLY AGREE
AND SO DOES THE MAYOR THAT THE
BEST PRACTICE IS PERMANENT
HOUSING.
AND THE BEST PRACTICE FOR
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS.
INDIVIDUALS IS PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
HOWEVER IN THE MEANTIME.
AND I REPEAT THAT IN THE
MEANTIME WE HAVE PEOPLE.
THE BARELY EXISTE.
LIVING WITHOUT.
HI BASIC HYGIENE.
WATER
LIVING WITHOUT.
BOB THE ABILITY TO EVEN CARE FOR
THEMSELVES OR THEIR FAMILIES OR
EVEN BE IN A POSITION TO GO. FOR
TRAINING OR EMPLOYMENT
BECAUSE THEY ARE LIVING ON THE
STREET.
AND I BELIEVE SO STRONGLY AND I
REALLY BESEECH YOU TO THINK
ABOUT.
THIS AS THE CRISIS TO RESPOND TO
IT AS WE WOULD A HURRICANE AS WE
WOULD AN EARTHQUAKE AS WE WOULD.
ANY OTHER NATURAL DISASTER
BECAUSE THIS IS A DISASTER.
THAT IS THE RESULT OF ANY NUMBER
OF CHOICES THAT HAVE COME
TOGETHER IN OUR SYSTEM.
AND IN OUR CITIES
AND I BELIEVE IF WE HAD FUNDING
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO STABILIZE
TO GET PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS TO
BE ABLE. TO.
.
MOVE THE ENCAMPMENTS.
IN A WAY WOULD THEN YOU COULD
HAVE.
THE ABILITY TO MUCH MORE
SYSTEMATICALLY.
ADDRESS THE ISSUE THAT IT IT
WOULD GIVE AND IT REQUIRES AN
INFLUX OF RESOURCES
BECAUSE AYE WHETHER IT IS
SACRAMENTO. OR SAN DIEGO OR LOS
ANGELES OR SAN JOSE.
IT IS CRIPPLING.
AND REALLY UNDERMINING.
OUR NEW STATUS.
AS THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THIS WORLD.
THANK YOU THEIR STEINBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APOLOGIZE WAS CHAIRMAN FOR
BEING ON A MOMENT LET MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING MY
COLLEAGUE JUST SAID AND.
AND I CHOOSE TO FOCUS MY
REMARKS OF. EVEN MORE
SPECIFICALLY ON WHAT'S MISSING
FROM OUR CURRENT SYSTEM BECAUSE
I THINK.
I HOPE WE ALL RECOGNISE BE
VIRTUE OF LIVING.
IN CALIFORNIA AND NOT JUST NOT
JUST OUR MAJOR URBAN CENTERS
POTENTIALLY SPREADING BEYOND.
THAT HOMELESSNESS IS IN FACT
A MAJOR PUBLIC HEALTH A PUBLIC
SAFETY.
DE CRISIS AND A CRISIS OF
CONSCIENCE.
I WANNA TALK ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
MISSING HERE IN SACRAMENTO
BECAUSE.
BOB IN OUR CITY.
SINCE I BECAME MAYOR NOW SIXTEEN
MONTHS AGO.
WE A FOCUSED ON ALL THE KEY
ELEMENTS THAT IT WILL TAKE WE
BELIEVED ACTUALLY GET THOUSANDS
OF PEOPLE OFF THE STREETS AND
HOUSED.
WE OUR RECIPIENT OF THE WHOLE
PERSON CARE.
GRANT APPROACH WHICH USUALLY
COUNTY.
BASED ARE ARE COUNTY DID NOT
APPLY OUR CITY DID.
WE HAVE SIXTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS
TO ENGAGE IN INTENSIVE OUTREACH.
FOR.
SEVERAL THOUSAND PEOPLE.
YOU KNOW THE PROBLEM WAS THAT
MANY OF THE PEOPLE THAT HOMELESS
FOR A LONG TIME.
YES THERE TREATMENT RESISTANT.
BUT THEY ALSO HAVEN'T BEEN
INTERVENED WITHIN AN ASSERTIVE
AND CONSISTENT WAY.
TO BUILD THE TRUST THAT ALLOWS
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT OF THOSE
PEOPLE TO AGREE EVENTUALLY MAY
TAKE MONTHS.
THE TO COME IN AND GET HELP.
WE HAVE THE MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES.
THROUGH THE COUNTY PROPOSITION
SIXTY THREE THE MEASURE I
AUTHORED WHEN HOSS SERVICES
ACTOR FORTY FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS.
TO PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH AND
WRAPAROUND SERVICES.
WHAT WE AND WE ARE WORKING HARD
TOWARD BUILDING AN INVENTORY OF
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
FOCUSED ON EFFICIENCY HOMES?
AND.
A AND AS MANY RENTAL UNITS AS
WE CAN BILL.
BUT.
TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS WITHOUT
AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE WITHOUT
THAT BRIDGE BETWEEN. THAT
ASSERTIVE OUTREACH AND PERMANENT
HOUSING.
YOU NEVER GET PEOPLE
FROM THE RIVER BANKS FOR THE
STREET INTO THE PERMANENT
HOUSING.
AND SO IT'S NOT AN EITHER OR.
AND I MIGHT SAY THAT WALL THE
BIG ELEVEN.
CITIES OF WHICH I AM THE CHAIR
OF PUT FORWARD A SPECIFIC CITY.
PROPOSAL.
THAT WOULD PROVIDE A BILLION
FIVE OF STATE FUNDING FOR.
WHATEVER IT TAKES FOR CITIES TO
RESPOND TO THE EMERGENCY WERE
ACTUALLY WORKING QUITE
COLLABORATIVE LEAN CLOSELY WITH
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS.
BECAUSE WE RECOGNIZE THAT THAT.
THAT.
IT'S NOT EITHER OR.
AND AND THAT.
WERE WERE MUCH BETTER OFF
WORKING TOGETHER WITHIN CITIES
AND COUNTIES BUT HERE AT THE
STATE HOUSE AS WELL.
AS WE ALL SEE THE RESOURCES TO
ADDRESS THIS CRISIS.
BUT OUR PIECE OF IT WHICH WE
MUST CALL OUT IS NOT BECAUSE
IT'S OUR PEACE.
COULD BE ADMINISTERED YOU KNOW.
BY ANY NONPROFIT BY ANYBODY.
IS TO ADDRESS.
THAT EMERGENCY PEACE WITH THE
CITY'S NEED FLEXIBLE DOLLARS DO
THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
SERVICES GO IN LA. AND
SACCHARINE ARE BEGINNING TO DO
WE HAVE ONE TRIAGE.
CENTER IN NORTH SACRAMENTO ITS
PILOT PUBLICIZED.
IT WAS CONTROVERSIAL BEEN A HUGE
SUCCESS.
WE'VE GOTTEN THREE HUNDRED
PEOPLE THREE HUNDRED MOST
INTRACTABLE HOMELESS PEOPLE OFF
THE STREETS.
AND YES IT'S NOT THE RITZ.
BUT. IT IS.
BRIDGE.
A PERMANENT HOUSING I HAVE NO
MORE CAPACITY IN MY CITY NOW
HAVE NOWHERE BUDGET DOLLARS.
TO BE ABLE TO EXPAND.
TRIPLE THAT CAPACITY WHICH IS
EXACTLY WHAT WE WANT TO DO TO
GET TWO THOUSAND PEOPLE.
OFF THE STREET WE NEED A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE HERE
FINANCIAL PARTNERSHIP.
AND IF THE SURPLUS IS WHAT I
KNOW YOU ALL HOPE IS.
AND YOUR LOOKING FOR ONE TIME
MONEY
WE WILL USE IT TO BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE AGAIN IN
COLLABORATION WITH OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS AND OUR NON PROFITS.
WE WILL USE IT TO BUILD THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE GENUINELY ALL THAT IT
TAKES.
TO MAKE A DRAMATIC IMPACT ON
THIS PROBLEM.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JEFF
CASSETTES KIM OF THE DIRECTOR OF
SAN FRANCISCO'S DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELESSNESS AND SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING.
MAYOR FARRELL REGRETS HE WASN'T
ABLE TO ATTEND THE MEETING TODAY
BUT OUT OF TO SHARE WITH YOU
SOME OF OUR THOUGHTS.
ON WHAT'S GOING ON IN IN OUR
CITY AND IN OUR STATE. OTHER
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELESSNESS IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING.
COMBINED SERVICES AND PROGRAMS
FROM MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS IN THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
INTO ONE DEPARTMENT WHERE WE NOW
HAVE ONE STRATEGY THAT WE'RE
WORKING TO IMPLEMENT IN ORDER TO
REDUCE. HOMELESSNESS AND IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
WAS HAVE BEEN DOING THIS WORK
FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS ARE
MOSTLY IN THE NONPROFIT SECTOR.
JUST TWENTY THREE MONTHS.
IN GOVERNMENT AND STARTED OUT
AS AN OUTREACH WORKER AND WILL
TELL YOU THAT I DON'T THINK MY
HEART COULD BREAK ANYMORE.
BUT SOMEHOW IT HAS MANAGED TO.
THE.
SERVE IN PERFECT STORM OF THE
HOUSING CRISIS IN THE STATE THE
LACK OF SHELTER IN CALIFORNIA.
THE.
OPIOID AND METH AMPHETAMINE
EPIDEMICS IN OUR STATE AND
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES HAVE
CREATED SOMETHING I'VE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE IN DOING THIS WORK
FOR NEARLY THIRTY YEARS AND NOT
JUST IN SAN FRANCISCO. OF BUT
ALL OVER THE STATE WITH PEOPLE.
LIVING BY SO MANY PEOPLE LIVING
SO DESPERATELY ON OUR STREETS.
WITH NOWHERE TO GO. NOWHERE TO
TAKE CARE OF THEIR BASIC NEEDS
AND.
AND JUST FALLING DEEPER DEEPER
INTO DESPAIR.
WHICH OFTENTIMES A LEAST MEANS
DEEPER AND DEEPER INTO A
ADDICTION AND UNTREATED MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES.
.
YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA HAS NEARLY A
QUARTER OF ALL HOMELESS PEOPLE.
IN THE UNITED STATES.
DURING THE LAST YEAR BETWEEN
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WE SAW A FIFTEEN
PERCENT INCREASE
I IN HOMELESSNESS IN OUR STATE.
ARE WE THIRTY FIVE OUT OF EVERY
TEN THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS ARE
HOMELESS WHICH IS TWICE THE
NATIONAL AVERAGE. AND SIXTY
EIGHT PERCENT OF THE ON
SHELTERED POPULAR ART SIXTY
PERCENT OF THE PEOPLE ON THE
STREETS.
IN CALIFORNIA ARE ON SHELTERED
WE HAVE NEARLY A FIFTH OF THE
COUNTRY'S ON SHELTER HOMELESS
POPULATION.
AND SAN FRANCISCO WE CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE ON OUR STREETS ON ANY
GIVEN NIGHT.
ABOUT FOUR THOUSAND OF THEM ARE
LITERALLY LIVING ON THE STREETS.
THE OTHERS ARE IN SHELTER AND
TRANSITIONAL HOUSING PROGRAMS
BUT THAT DOESN'T REALLY.
EXPLAIN THE FULL SCOPE OF THE
PROGRAM THAT AND OF SACRAMENTO
IN LA ARE ARE DEALING WITH WHICH
SET THAT SEVENTY FIVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE ON ANY GIVEN NIGHT. WE
ESTIMATE ABOUT TWENTY ONE
THOUSAND PEOPLE A YEAR ARE
HOMELESS IN SAN FRANCISCO ALONE.
COMING IN AND OUT OF OUR CITY
ARE EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS.
ASSEMBLY CISCO'S INVESTED I
THINK WELL.
IN THIS ISSUE I MET DEPARTMENTS
BUDGET IS APPROXIMATELY TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
AB JUST UNDER TWO HUNDRED
MILLION OF THAT COMES FROM
COUNTY FUNDS.
WE HAVE A MORE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING PRATAPADITYA
THAN ANY OTHER CITY.
IN THE UNITED STATES OUT AND
ALTHOUGH WE ONLY HAVE TWENTY
FOUR PERCENT OF THE BAY AREA'S
HOMELESS POPULATION WITH ABOUT A
THIRD OF THE BAY AREA SHELTERS.
AND WE HAVE ABOUT ALMOST FIFTY
OR FORTY FIVE PERCENT OF THE
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
.
SO I WAS ASKED TO TALK ABOUT.
HYPOTHETICALLY WHAT WOULD WE DO
WITH A INCREASED INVESTMENTS
FROM THE STATE ON A ONE TIME
BASIS AND I I APPRECIATE.
HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE
THIS DISCUSSION AND I THINK THE
IDEA OF HAVING A FLEXIBLE PART
OF FUNDING THAT'S AVAILABLE FOR
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO DETERMINE
HOW TO USE A. IS VERY MUCH
NEEDED UP BY THE STATE.
WE IN IN SAN FRANCISCO WHERE WE
TO HAVE SAY THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL FUNDING
THAT WAS JUST ONE TIME.
WE COULD PREVENT A THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
FROM BECOMING HOMELESS.
WE COULD HELP FIVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE UP PERMANENTLY EXIT
HOMELESSNESS ARE THROUGH OUR
TEMPORARY RENT SUBSIDY PROGRAM
CALLED RAPID RE HOUSING. AND WE
CAN PROVIDE SHELTER TO
ADDITIONAL SEVEN HUNDRED TO
EIGHT HUNDRED PEOPLE A YEAR.
IF WE WERE ABLE TO HAVE THE
FUNDS TO PURCHASE ADDITIONAL
SHELTER FACILITIES WHICH WE WE
DESPERATELY NEED.
.
I THINK IT'S ALSO IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT YOU DON'T.
ALL OF OUR CITIES ARE IN
DIFFERENT PLACES.
IN TERMS OF WHAT OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE LOOKS LIKE.
AGAIN CENTER CISCO DOES HAVE
QUITE A BIT OF PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING BUT WE HOUSE
WE HELP FIFTY PEOPLE EVERY WEEK
EXIT HOMELESSNESS WHICH I'M
INCREDIBLY PROUD OF AND GRATEFUL
FOR. A CITY THAT DOES SUCH
AMAZING WORK BUT EVERY WEEK.
APPROXIMATELY A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY NEWLY HOMELESS PEOPLE ARE
IN SAN FRANCISCO SO WE KEEP
RUNNING ON THAT.
YOU KNOW WE KEEP OPERATING THE
SAME WAY WE'VE BEEN DOING
BUSINESS ON WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GET THE JOB DONE. SO I THINK
FOCUS ON HAVING THE OPPORTUNITY
TO USE THESE FUNDS TO FOCUS ON
PREVENTION AND DIVERSION.
TO FOCUS ON ADDRESSING
TEMPORARY SHELTER NEEDS.
AND TO FOCUS ON THINGS LIKE
RAPID RE HOUSING WHICH USE THE
PRIVATE MARKET IN ORDER TO HELP
HOMELESS PEOPLE FIND A PLACE TO
LIVE ARE INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT
COMPONENTS. AND I KNOW THAT THE
OTHER QUESTION.
THAT SOME OF YOUR PROBABLY
ASKING IT'S WE JUST KEEP
THROWING MONEY AT THE PROBLEM.
IS IT CAN GET BETTER.
HOW DO WE KNOW IT'S GOING TO
GET BETTER BY THINK WE KNOW? YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THINGS.
THAT WOULD INDICATE THAT IT
CRAFTING CREASED INVESTMENTS
WILL HAVE AN IMPACT SOME OF ITS
SORT OF COUNTER FACTUAL LIKE WE
KNOW THE FACT THAT. THE HUD
BUDGET CUTS BUDGET AUTHORITY IS
A TWENTY PERCENT OF WHAT IT WAS
IN NINETEEN SEVENTY EIGHT IN
CURRENT DOLLARS AND THAT
CORRESPONDS DIRECTLY TO THE RISE
OF MODERN DAY HOMELESSNESS IN
THE UNITED STATES.
BUT WE KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA'S
ALL DECREASE IN FUNDING FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
STARTING IN ABOUT TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHT AND THAT WE KNOW
DURING THAT TIME WHERE WE HAD
SEEN A DECREASE IN HOMELESSNESS.
FOOT FOR QUITE SOMETIME IN THE
STATE AYE THAT SEEM TO HAVE LED
DIRECTLY TO A AN INCREASE AYE IN
HOMELESSNESS AND I THINK OUR BUT
OUR OWN EXPERIENCE IN THOSE ARE
SORT OF A. COUNTER FACTUAL THING
SOME OF THE POSITIVE I IMPACTS I
THINK.
CAN BE SEEN IN SAN FRANCISCO
WHERE WE HAVE A RECENTLY
INCREASED OUR INVESTMENTS UNDER
THE LEADERSHIP OF MERRILY. AND
ALTHOUGH IT'S NOTHING TO WRITE
HOME ABOUT AYE WE SAW A ONE
PERCENT DECREASE IN HOMELESSNESS
FROM TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
SEVENTEEN.
BUCKING THE TRENDS OF ALMOST
EVERY CITY ON THE WEST COAST AND
ALL THAT MOST EVERY CITY
NATIONALLY AND CERTAINLY.
BUCKING THE TRENDS AYE IN
CALIFORNIA AND WHEN WE DUG DEEP
INTO WHY THAT HAPPENED. OUT WE
LOOKED AT WORD WE INVEST IN WHAT
WERE THE OUTCOME SO WE FOUND
THAT THE AREAS WHERE WE
INCREASED OUR INVESTMENTS AND
YOU'VE HOMELESSNESS.
I IN FAMILY HOMELESSNESS AND
VETERANS HOMELESSNESS SAW SOME
REALLY GOOD I IMPACTS WE SOLVE
OF BETWEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO THIRTY
PERCENT REDUCTION. AYE IN
CHRONIC VETERANS HOMELESSNESS WE
SAW THIRTEEN PERCENT REDUCTION
IN YOUTH HOMELESSNESS IN A
TWELVE PERCENT REDUCTION IN
FAMILY HOMELESSNESS DUE TO THESE
INCREASED INVESTMENTS AYE THAT
WERE MADE. UNDER THE LEADERSHIP
OF MERRILY AND I BELIEVE THAT
SIDE NATIONALLY.
AND BOTH YOU KNOW LOCALLY IN
WITHIN OUR STATE THERE'S PLENTY
OF EVIDENCE TO SHOW THAT WHEN
YOU MAKE SMART. TARGETED
INVESTMENTS BASED ON AYE DATA
AND BASED ON WHAT THE COMMUNITY
HAS IDENTIFIED BY ITS NEEDS TO
BE A WE CAN WE CAN MAKE PROGRESS
WE'VE DONE IT BEFORE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND I'M I'M
CONFIDENT THAT WE CAN WE CAN DO
IT AGAIN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
I'VE QUESTION FOR MAYOR
STEINBERG IN YOUR TESTIMONY
MENTIONED FLEXIBILITY. NAM WAS
THAT MEAN.
WELL FIRST OF ALL ANY PUBLIC
MONEY OF COURSE NEEDS TO COME
WITH A OUTCOME BASED
ACCOUNTABILITY AND SO WE WOULD
EXPECT.
UPON RECEIPT OF THESE RESOURCES
TO ACTUALLY DEMONSTRATE.
THAT WE WERE USING THE
RESOURCES TO ACTUALLY HELP GET.
PEOPLE OFF THE STREET.
BUT WHEN I WENT WHAT WE MEAN BY
FLEXIBILITY IS THE ABILITY TO
USE THE MONEY.
FOR A VARIETY OF THINGS THAT
ARE GOING TO BRIDGE BETWEEN.
THE OUT REACH.
THE INTERVENTION.
AND THE PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING.
NAVIGATION CENTERS TRIAGE
CENTERS.
ANY OTHER FORMS OVER EMERGENCY
HOUSING.
OUT REACH.
WHAT WHATEVER IT TAKES THE
ABILITY HAVE NAVIGATORS?
ON THE GROUND TO HELP. A WITH
THAT ASSERTIVE INTERVENTION. ALL
THOSE PIECES THAT AREN'T.
USUALLY THE SUBJECT OF A
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE WHEN IT
COMES FOR EXAMPLE TO. THE
DEVELOPMENT OF A LARGE SCALE
HOUSING BOND OR.
BUT OUR ARE A NECESSARY PART OF
THE CONTINUUM WE WANT THAT
FLEXIBILITY. BUT WERE WILLING TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE IN TERMS OF
THE RESULT THAT IT BRINGS.
DID YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OF LET ME
FIRST START BY THANKING ALL OF
YOU FOR.
FOR YOUR PRESENTATION AND AS I
SAID TO THE BIG TEN WHEN THEY'RE
UP A COUPLE WEEKS AGO MINUS MERE
STEINBERG WHEN I HAD A CHANCE TO
SIT DOWN WITH THEM.
AS THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
HOUSING COMMITTEE.
WHAT YOU ARE SAYING DUB TELLS
VERY MUCH WITH WHAT MANY OF US
HAVE BEEN SO
THE LEGISLATURE?
WHICH IS WE NOT ONLY HAVE A
HOUSING CRISIS BUT WE HAVE A AND
THE MOST INTENSE HOMELESSNESS
CRISIS REALLY IN OUR STATES.
HISTORY AND ARE AS SOMEONE WHO
IS A CO AUTHOR OF AB THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY ONE I VERY MUCH SUPPORT
THE SIZE OF THE MONEY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN FACT I MIGHT
SUGGEST.
SINCE THE SENATE HAS A TWO
BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL I THINK
THE ASSEMBLY SHOULD HAVE A TWO
BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL I HAVE
SOME THOUGHTS ON. A WHERE ELSE
WE OUGHT TO THINK ABOUT SPENT
SPENDING MONEY IN THIS AREA.
THAT BEING SAID I I THINK THAT
THE QUESTION I'M REALLY
INTERESTED IN.
TO GET TO THE CHAIRS QUESTION
IS IS HOW THIS MONEY IS GOING TO
BE USED IN AND LET ME SAY THE
FOLLOWING.
AND I'M JUST NOW SPEAKING FOR
SAN FRANCISCO WE SPEND ABOUT
OVER THREE HUNDRED MILLION A
YEAR ON HOMELESSNESS WE'VE BEEN
SPENDING AT THAT LEVEL CORRECTED
FOR.
INFLATION OVER TIME FOR FOR
QUITE SOME TIME
AND THROUGH SEVEN MAYORS WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANT DROP IN HOMELESSNESS
IN FACT THE ONE PERCENT DROP
THAT WE JUST HEARD. THAT WAS
ACTUALLY HEROIC DROP COMPARED TO
WHAT IS HAPPENING IN OTHER PARTS
OF THE STATE.
SO JUST ARE SITTING ALONE WE
SPENT BILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
AND YET WE HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO
BRING HOMELESSNESS DOWN AND SO.
I THINK FOR ME.
.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION
ABOUT EVIDENCE BASED FACT BASED
APPROACHES TO HOMELESSNESS I
KNOW ALL THREE OF YOU KNOW.
THE FIRST I HOUSING FIRST MODEL
THE IMPORTANCE OF PERMITS
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING AND.
AND A DISCUSSION WE'RE HAVING
ABOUT WHAT FOR
CIVIL DOLLARS MEAN.
IN A SOMEWHAT AT THIS MOMENT A
BIT UNDEFINED WAY VERSES WANTING
TO FOCUS ON.
SUPPORT OF HOUSING AND LET ME
SAY JUST TO BE CLEAR WHEN I
REFERRED TO SUPPORT OF HOUSING
I'M NOT NECESSARILY SAYING WE
HAVE TO BUILD AND CONSTRUCT WITH
THESE DOLLARS. BUT I THINK PAIN
FOR OPERATING COSTS FOR THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT RUN THIS LONG
TERM RENTAL ASSISTANCE THESE ARE
THE THINGS THAT HAVE BEEN PROVEN
OVER TIME. TO ADDRESS
HOMELESSNESS AND AND I'VE NO
DOUBT THAT WHAT I'M ALSO HEARING
OF OTHER FLEXIBLE. SOLUTIONS
WILL ALSO HELP BUT.
MY QUESTION IS.
HOW WE ARE I HEARD A LITTLE BIT
FROM DISTRICTS THIS GIVE HOW WE
WOULD SPEND? IN SAN FRANCISCO
ARE THERE SPECIFIC PLANS FOR
EACH OF THE CITIES
ON HOW THEY WOULD SPEND SO THAT
WE COULD JUST HAVE A SENSE OF OF
THIS BECAUSE I HEAT AT THE END
OF. A YEAR I APPRECIATE WE ALL
HAVE TO BE HELD ACCOUNTABLE BUT
I HATE TO SAY WE SPENT A BILLION
AND A HALF AND OUR NUMBERS.
HAVEN'T DROPPED NOW OR HAVEN'T
DROPPED BY MORE THAN ONE PERSON
SO LOVE TO JUST GET A LITTLE BIT
MORE TO CENSOR OF THAT.
SURE TO GO FIRST IN I HAVE SOME
THOUGHTS
THE HAPPY TO ON.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES.
.
ARE.
I BUDGET THIS STARTS JULY ONE IS
FOR FOUR HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS ADDRESSING
HOMELESSNESS.
OF THAT TWO HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT
MILLION ARE OF THIS THROUGH THE
BOND THE HHH BOND THAT WAS
APPROVED.
THE BALLOTS THOUGH IS FOR.
RAPID RE HOUSING THE LOS ANGELES
HOMELESS SERVICES AUTHORITY AND
EXISTING.
PROJECTS AND AGENCIES THAT WE
WORK WITH.
AS YOU STATED. YOU WE CAN PUT.
MONEY IN VARIOUS PLACES BUT
WHAT'S TURNING OUT BECAUSE OF
THE IN FLOW AND BECAUSE.
OF THAT.
THE THE NEED.
IT IS TO THE NEED TO BE ABLE TO
DO IT ALL.
AND TO BE ABLE TO DO IT ALL THAT
HAS.
.
AT THE SAME TIME BECAUSE.
OF ALL OF THESE INTERVENTIONS
ARE NEEDED.
BOB BASED ON THE.
FORMULA THAT WE USE THAT. BATES
DID WHICH IS TIED TO THE
PERCENTAGE OF HOMELESS
POPULATION YOU HAVE IN EACH
CITY.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
PROJECTS
THAT UNDER THIS FORMULA WE WOULD
I RECEIVE APPROXIMATELY THREE
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
WE HAVE.
LOOK CAREFULLY AT THE THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO DO AND I'M HAPPY
TO SHARE WITH YOU WHERE WE ARE
NOW I MEAN IT IS THAT DRAFT BUT
IT GIVES YOU A SENSE. OF THE
DIRECTION WE'D LIKE TO TAKE.
OF THAT THREE HUNDRED EIGHTY
MILLION WE FIFTY MILLION OF IT
TOO PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
GAPS
BECAUSE AS YOU KNOW THE. ON TAX
REFORM.
.
CHANGE IT TAX REFORM WHICH IS
APPROVED IT CHANGE THE VALUE IF
YOU WILL OF THAT NINE PERCENT
CREDITS IN THE LIKE THAT WE EACH
HISTORICALLY USE THE CALL THAT I
YOU OF THOSE.
NOT BEING AS HIGH AND IN THE
PAST WHICH CREATES THAT GAP
BASED ON THE EXPECTATION OF THE
FINANCING SO WE ANTICIPATE THAT
IF WE WERE ABLE TO PUT. FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS AND ANTICIPATING
THE GAPS THAT WILL COME UP
BECAUSE OF THAT CHANGE THAT WE'D
BE ABLE TO ADD ANOTHER TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY.
ADDITIONAL UNITS OF SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING.
OUR TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION THOUGH THE LION SHARE OF
IT WOULD GO TO TEMPORARY LEGAL
ACTION CAN ASK WERE QUICKER
QUESTION THERE BECAUSE.
AYE I HEAR A LITANY OF OPTIONS
BUT I'D I CAN GET IN MY HEAD
WHETHER WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
BUILDING.
REMODELING SOMETHING OR JUST.
MEAN EXACTLY WHAT WE TALKED WE
HAVE TAUGHT THERE ACTUALLY FIFTY
UNITS WERE TALKING.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT FILLING GAPS
FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION THAT'S WHAT
I ASSUME FOR ONE LETTER THE
FIFTY MILLION WOULD BE FOR THAT
THAT.
I TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION WAS IDENTIFIED FOR.
TEMPORARY SHELTER NAVIGATION
CENTERS.
BRIDGE HOUSING MEETING EMERGENCY
WE USED TO CALL IT TRANSITION
BUT NO BUT BRIDGE HOUSING IN.
AND THAT WOULD ADD FOUR
THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
ADDITIONAL BETS AND THAT ALSO
INCLUDE SOMETHING THAT WE'VE.
BEEN DOING FOR THE LAST TWO
YEARS NOW AND THAT'S MOBILE
HYGIENE CENTERS.
AND I HAVE TO SAY SOME OF THIS
MODEL ARE MUCH OF THIS MODEL
DOES COME FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
INCLUDING OUR FORMER.
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH SERVICES
DIRECTOR.
AND A BRILLIANT CORNERS THAT
DOES THE.
MASTER LEASING AS WELL AS.
.
A LOT OF A MAY WHICH IS PROVIDES
THAT.
.
HI GENE CENTER IN THE TOILETS ON
A MOBILE BASIS AND IT HAS MADE
SUCH A TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE FOR
PEOPLE TO HAVE A SENSE OF
DIGNITY AND KNOWING THAT.
ONCE TWICE A WEEK THEY CAN GO TO
AN APPOINTED SPOT AND KNOW THEY
CAN GET WHAT WHAT THEY NEED IN
TERMS OF HYGIENE. MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR BUT NOT
SO LIKE THE ABILITY TO DRESS
OCEARCH IN THIS OP ED GO AHEAD
FOR HIGH YIELD MY TIMES ARE
GOING TO NOW.
.
VISIT ONE OF THE.
BUT I THINK IT.
ALL OF THE BIG ELEVEN CITIES
CERTAINLY.
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF OF DOING
THE EXACT.
THE WORK THAT WE JUST HEARD TO
ACTUALLY BREAK DOWN OUR NUMBERS
BASED UPON THE ESTIMATED
PERCENTAGE IN SO WE'RE HAPPY TO
GET ALL OF THAT TO THE
COMMITTEE.
THE PART AND I DON'T THINK WE'VE
EMPHASIZED ENOUGH THOUGH IN
ANSWER TO YOUR YOUR.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU YOUR
QUESTION ABOUT HOW TO UE.
CONSISTENTLY HOUSE MORE PEOPLE
AND YET THE HOMELESS NUMBERS
KEEP GOING UP I MEAN THAT'S THE.
REAL CONUNDRUM HERE RIGHT THE
PYRRHIC VICTORIES ARE THE HOUSE.
SO MANY PEOPLE ONLY TO SEE THE
PROBLEM NOT GET ANY BETTER.
AND WHAT WE BELIEVE IS THE
ANSWER AT LEAST PARTLY LIES IN
HAVING THE FLEXIBILITY.
TO SOME STATE RESOURCES ON THE
PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION SIDE.
IN OTHER WORDS THE PIPE THAT THE
FOR THE FAMILY.
SINGLE PARENT USUALLY THE SINGLE
MOM.
THIS THE INDIVIDUAL WHO HAVE IS
ONE BROKEN DOWN CAR.
ONE RENT INCREASE
ONE LOST JOB.
ONE INJURY.
AWAY FROM GOING FROM BEING
HOUSED.
TO COUCH SURFING.
TO.
OVERCROWDED SHELTER.
TO THE STREET.
AND OF WE HAD SOME FLEXIBILITY
AND THE ABILITY WITH THE RIGHT
SORTS OF VERIFICATION TO.
PREVENT SOMEBODY FROM.
BECOMING.
PART OF THAT NEW COHORT.
WE THINK THAT WE WOULD BE ABLE
TO SHOW A GREATER THAN ONE
PERCENT NET DECREASE IN OUR
CITY.
IN TERMS OF THE ACTUAL NUMBERS
WHEN IT COMES TO THE POINT IN
TIME COUNT.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR US SAW
OUR QUESTION ABOUT S. B. THREE
LOW WHICH WE APPROVED LAST YEAR
THAT. IS GOING TO PUT A FOUR
BILLION DOLLAR BOND TO ADDRESS.
ALMOST AS AN AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN FRONT OF VOTERS THIS YEAR AND
I THINK OF HISTORY IS A GUIDE
THE VOTERS WILL PROBABLY APPROVE
THAT SO I WONDERED HOW THIS
REQUEST FOR ONE AND A HALF
BILLION DOLLARS. AYE INTERFACES
WITH THAT IS THIS IS THIS IS IN
ADDITION COMPLEMENT OR REALLY
AND I GUESS.
BUT ONE TIME MONEY WE'RE NOT
ASKING FOR ON GOING MONEY WHICH
IS
I KNOW ONE OF THE CONCERNS.
FROM EVERYBODY IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT WHEN I WAS HERE
FROM GOVERNORS AND FOR MEMBERS
OF THE MINORITY PARTY BUT
EVERYONE IS THAT.
AND YOU MAKE LONG TERM
OBLIGATIONS AND YOU KNOW IT
NEVER THEN GOES AWAY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ONE TIME MONEY.
SO THAT WE CAN PURCHASE THE
WAREHOUSE.
FOR THE TRIAGE CENTERS SO THAT
WE CAN.
SET UP A RENT STABILIZATION
FUND.
AND SO I THINK THAT'S IMPORTANT
TO NOTE A BIG DIFFERENCE IN ONE
TIME MONEY FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR. EMERGENCY RESPONSE.
AND ONGOING FUNDING.
ALRIGHT PET BUT I DON'T THINK
IT'S UNDERSTOOD THAT IS PROBABLY
THE REQUEST IS IN ADDITION TO
THAT YES.
.
THE.
AND I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU
THAT THIS IS A AN
EPIDEMIC.-CRISIS THAT'S KIND OF
EXISTENTIAL CRISIS THAT SPACE IN
CALIFORNIA.
WE'RE SEEING HOMELESSNESS IN
PLACES WHERE WE'VE NEVER SEEN IT
BEFORE.
THE.
PROBLEM THAT I HAVE IS IS JUST
WONDERING IF WE'RE NOT.
BEING OPEN TO ARE OPTIMISTIC
ABOUT OUR CHANCES OF SOLVING THE
PROBLEM AND A AND A IF I'M DOING
THE MATH RIGHT AND IF YOU HAD
JUST JUST THE MONEY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THIS YEAR THAT
WERE BILLION DOLLARS. FOR THAT
BOND AND THE ONE HALF BILLION
DOLLARS IN THIS REQUEST
TOGETHER AND THEN IF YOU.
COMPARE THAT AGAINST THAT THE
HIGH END OF THE RANGE THAT YOU
MENTIONED WHICH IS AS MANY AS A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THOUSAND
HOMELESS IN CALIFORNIA. ON ANY
GIVEN NIGHT IF IF I'M GETTING MY
ZEROS RIGHT THAT'S.
AS A LITTLE OVER FORTY TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER HOMELESS.
PERSON THIS YEAR THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SPENDING.
AND THAT'S IN ADDITION THAT JUST
THIS YEAR THAT'S THAT'S IN
ADDITION TO YOU KNOW TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE HAD.
.
ARE WE HEADED OUT ON A TWO
BILLION DOLLAR PROPOSAL AND I'M
SURE WE'LL BE SPENDING MORE IN
FUTURE YEARS SIGH I JUST. CAN'T
HELP BUT WONDERING IF
WE'RE TAKING WE'RE GOING TO
SIMPLE MINDED ABOUT THIS SUPER
JUST OF THROWING MONEY AT THE
PROBLEM ISN'T GOING TO FIX IT.
IT'S REMINDS ME OF SOMEONE
COMING TO THE DOCTOR AND THEY
SAY DOCTOR THE HEADACHE AND THE
DOCTOR SAYS WELL YOU HAVE A
BRAIN TUMOR.
BUT YOU KNOW THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE
A HEADACHE BUT HERE LET ME
PRESCRIBED SOME ASPIRIN YOU KNOW
BECAUSE WE UNDERSTAND THAT THE.
THE ROOT CAUSES OF HOMELESSNESS
IN IT'S A COMPLEX AND
MULTIFACETED PROBLEM IT'S IT'S
NOT JUST THE AFFORDABILITY OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA BUT THERE'S A
OF MENTAL HEALTH ASPECT OF
SUBSTANCE ABUSE THERE'S SOME.
TECHNOLOGICAL UNEMPLOYMENT
THROWN IN THERE THERE'S OTHERS
AGING ISSUES AND I JUST I I'M A
LITTLE SKEPTICAL THE JUST
THROWING MORE MORE MONEY AT THE
PROBLEM WOULD. WHAT HELP I
WONDER IF IS ANYONE TAKE A
HOLISTIC LOOK AT THIS TO TRYING
TO SIGN UP FOR IF WE? AS A
SOCIETY IF WE IF WE PUT OUR FOOT
DOWN SAID NO MORE. THAT WE'RE
NOT GOING TO ACCEPT HOMELESSNESS
IS PART OF OUR SOCIETY WHAT
WOULD THAT COST TO IMPLEMENT
THAT IP HOUSING LAWS MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
SO MORE LONG TERM.
MORE SO THAN IN EMERGENCY FOR
FUNDING.
AND FUNDING FROM KRETZ CRACK.
AND IF I MAY I CAN SHOW YOU HOW
WE WOULD GET TO FIFTY ONE
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
TWENTY. ANGELENOS ASSISTED WITH
THIS FORMULA AND THESE FUNDS
BECAUSE WE HAVE BEEN.
.
S. HOT LOOKING AT IT FROM A
HOLISTIC.
WE'VE LOOKED AT THE PREVENTION
AND PARTICULARLY WITH.
THAT THE KIND OF INFLOW THAT
WE'RE ALL FACING.
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT THE PUBLIC
HEALTH AND THAT. JUST SORT OF.
ALMOST DISCARDING OF HUMAN
BEINGS
ON THIS BY THE TIME THEY ARE
LIVING YEARS ON THE STREET.
AND AS I MENTIONED EARLIER WE
THAT TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION WHICH SHOULD BE THE CORE
OF WHAT WE GET THAT WOULD
ADDRESS NAVIGATION CENTERS AND.
TEMPORARY SHELTERS AND ITS
SHELTER.
MEANING.
.
BRIDGE HOUSING.
I TO DEFY HAVE HOUSING THAT
STENOSIS ALTERED NOT WHERE YOU
LEAVE AT NINE IN THE MORNING.
AND YOU HAVE TO STAND IN LINE TO
SEE IF THEY'LL BE A BET FOR YOU
AT SIX.
THIS IS.
HOUSING THAT WHILE YOU'RE THEIR
IT IS SURE YEAH YOUR PLACE TO
LIVE.
AND THAT'S AND THAT'S SOMEWHAT
OF I'M.
DEPARTURE FROM THE TRADITIONAL
SHELTER.
APPROACH.
THE MOBILE HYGIENE SINNERS AND.
ARE PROJECTS ON CITY OWNED
PROPERTIES
ANON SITES FOR PERMANENT.
WE PROPOSED IN LOS ANGELES
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
SITES THAT STILL HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE ENTITLEMENTS WHY
CAN'T WE PUT TEMPORARY HOUSING
ON THOSE SITES.
OUT THIRTY TWO MILLION FOR RAPID
RE HOUSING WHICH GOES TO THE
POINT ABOUT. PEOPLE WHO ARE
RIGHT THERE ONE LITTLE THING AND
ALSO EVEN IN THE COUNTY THEIR.
FUNDING LEGAL SERVICES TO
ASSIST SO THAT PEOPLE HAVE
RESOURCES ARE THE HUMAN
RESOURCES TO THAT.
NEGOTIATE WITH LANDLORDS
TERRORISM REALLY BUT I
APPRECIATE THE ANSWER A AND I
UNDERSTAND YOUR ANSWER THE
QUESTION OF HOW YOU WOULD SPEND
THE MONEY. IN THIS PROPOSAL BUT
I WAS ASKING A DIFFERENT
QUESTION OF WE KNOW WE DON'T
HAVE A CHAIR TO SMALL THEY DON'T
HAVE IT WE DON'T HAVE A CURE
HERE SIR I MEAN REALLY. WITH
ADDITIONAL CURE.
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ALL DO IS
TO MAKE THE PROBLEM
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER AND HELP AS
MANY HUMAN BEINGS BY THE WAY
ALONG THE WAY?
AT AS WE CAN BUT.
THE FRUSTRATION.
LIES IN.
THAT THE FACT THAT THERE ISN'T A
CURE BUT WE BELIEVE IN OUR
CITIES.
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY BEGIN TO
SEE A DOWNWARD TREND IF WE FOCUS
ON BOTH PREVENTION.
EARLY INTERVENTION AND THE
ELEMENTS OF THE CONTINUUM OF
CARE THAT WE HAVE DESCRIBED.
THAT ARE PROVEN TO WORK
IF ONLY WE HAVE THE CAPACITY TO
BE ABLE TO.
TO DO MORE.
MARK I THINK WE'RE ON THE SAME
TEAM HERE AND YEAH I JUST WHAT
MAKES SURE THAT WERE. THAT WERE
TAKING A HOLISTIC APPROACH TO
THE PROBLEM AND NOT JUST
THROWING MONEY AT KNOW THAT YET.
CLINTON QUESTION FOR THE PANEL
WE THINK IS THE APPROPRIATE
BALANCE BETWEEN EMERGENCY AND
LONG TERM HOUSING FUNDING.
HER SWORD LIKE ALAN'S NAY I
THINK IT DEPENDS ON THE
COMMUNITY YOU KNOW QUITE
FRANKLY.
AND WHERE THEY ARE IN TERMS OF
THEIR INVESTMENTS I THINK THE
COUNTIES KNOW BEST WHERE TO PUT
THOSE FUNDS BUT I WOULD LIKE TO
ADD. BEING THAT HOMELESSNESS AYE
ISN'T ONLY AFFECTING PEOPLE WHO
ARE ON THE STREETS IT'S ALSO
AFFECTING OUR OUR COMMUNITIES.
WITH.
HEPATITIS.
WE'VE HAD OUTBREAKS OF OTHER
DISEASES ENCAMPMENTS.
THE CRIME ASSOCIATED WITH IT
AND OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES
SO I THINK I CAN SAN FRANCISCO.
WE WOULD.
WANT TO BE ABLE TO DEPLOY THE
MONEY AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO
WE WOULD WANT TO FOCUS ON
EMERGENCY SHELTER.
BECAUSE WE HAVE INVESTED MUCH
EMERGENCY SHELTER FOR THE PAST
FIFTEEN YEARS WE'VE BEEN
INVESTING MOSTLY IN HOUSING
OTHER COMMUNITIES MAY HAVE A
DIFFERENT.
APPROACH TO IT AND ALSO FOR US
AS WE WANTED TO PLAY THE FUNDING
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE SO RATHER
THAN TRYING TO BUILD MORE
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
MASTER LEASING OR USING. A RENT
SUBSIDIES ARE THINGS THAT WE CAN
I THINK ARE ARE CRITICAL FOR
SAN FRANCISCO BUT IMAGINE THE
SITUATION IS QUITE DIFFERENT AND
IN SACRAMENTO IN LA.
YOU KNOW HOW WE DO THIS FORMULA
WISE.
I THINK THERE NEEDS TO BE A
BALANCE I RECOGNIZE A COUPLE
THINGS THAT THERE ARE SOME
PERMITS SUPPORTIVE HOUSING
EFFORTS IN THE PIPELINE THAT NO
PLACE LIKE HOME INITIATIVE
WHICH.
I HOPE THE LEGISLATURE WILL.
SAID ESSENTIALLY POSITIVELY
REFERENDA AND PUT ON THE BALLOT
AND THAT'S TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
YOU'VE GOT TO PROPOSITION.
WE GET THE HOUSING BOND AND
HAVE A LAST YEAR'S PRODUCERS ALL
GREAT WORK BY THE WAY.
THAT THAT IS THE BEGINNING
THERE'S NEED FOR MORE PERMANENT
SUPPORTIVE HOUSING.
.
BUT WE NEED.
I MEAN TO REALLY MAKE AN IMPACT
TO GET PEOPLE OFF THE STREET
INTO TRUE.
ONE FORMER KNOW THEIR OF TRIAGE.
WE NEED HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS HERE STATEWIDE IN ORDER
TO MAKE A REAL IMPACT AND CLOSER
TO BILLION.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT WE NEED. AND
I AM I HOPE THAT IN THE
COMBINATION.
OF.
HOWEVER THE SORTS OUT OF PLEA
IN THAT SURPLUS IS LARGE.
THAT JUNE THE CITIES AND THE
COUNTIES THAT THERE CAN BE.
I'M INAPPROPRIATE DIVISION AND
BALANCE THAT GIVES US THOSE
KINDS OF RESOURCES EARTHLY PANEL
ATTORNEY NUMBERS OUT THERE THAT
THAT REALLY THE INTERVENTION ON
THIS AND HOMELESSNESS VERSES OF
THE SEASON WITH MILLION.
ALMOST LONGTIME THEIR NUMBERS
THAT SHOW ALL YEAH.
.
AND I CAN'T GIVE YOU THE EXACT
NUMBERS UP BE HAPPY TO SEND THEM
BUT THE.
.
WHEN YOU INTERVENE WITH SOMEONE
WHO. IS EITHER ABOUT TO BE
HOMELESS OR HAS ONLY BEEN
HOMELESS FOR SHORT AMOUNT OF
TIME.
THE NEED FOR THE EXTENSIVE
SERVICES AND THE COST ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT IS GREATLY REDUCED
BECAUSE YOU ARE. SORT OF.
CATCHING THEM AS THEY FALL AND
WITH SUPPORT IN THE SHORT TERM.
THEY CAN AND BECAUSE THE FACT IS
IN LOS ANGELES WE PROBABLY HAVE
AND THAT'S ONE OF THE HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND PEOPLE A YEAR
WHO CYCLE IN AND OUT OF
HOMELESSNESS.
MANY. AND MOST OF THEM SELF
RESOLVE THEIR IN THEIR CAR
COUPLE WEEKS AND THEN THERE'S
THE PLACE THAT.
BUT WHEN SOMETHING HAPPENS AND
THEY CAN'T SELF RESOLVE THIS
SOONER THAT THEY ARE.
GIVEN ASSISTANCE.
THE.
CHEAPER IT IS TO HELP THEM.
AND THE GREATER LIKELIHOOD THAT
THEY WILL NOT.
FALL BACK INTO HOMES.
I WOULD JUST.
ED PUT IT THIS WAY MAYBE TO USE
AN ANALOGY THEY'RE GOING
UNDERSTANDS THAT WE HAVE A STAGE
FOR SYSTEM.
RIGHT VULGATE CANCER.
WHICH STATE FOR SYSTEM.
AND WE SPEND BILLIONS TRYING TO
CATCH OUR TAILS TO. ADDRESS THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE AN INTERVENE.
PRIOR TO STAGE FOR.
IF SOMEBODY IS HOMELESS FOR THE
FIRST TIME.
OR HAS A FIRST MENTAL SERIOUS
MENTAL HEALTH EPISODE AND WE
INTERVENE AT THAT POINT.
AND THERE HOMELESS FOR THREE
DAYS INSTEAD OF.
THREE YEARS.
OR GOD FORBID THREE DECADES.
THEY HAVE A MUCH BETTER CHANCE
OF SUCCESS AND WE HAVE A MUCH
BETTER CHANCE AT SAVING.
OF THOSE EXPENSIVE RESOURCES ON
THE BACK AND.
CHIU.
THANK YOU END UP I WANT TO THANK
MAYOR STEINBERG FOR
ARTICULATING.
Y. THE FLEXIBILITY SUPPORT
BECAUSE I THAT'S I THINK A
QUESTION THAT MANY OF US HAVE
BEEN GRAPPLING WITH AND I THINK
YOU CLEARLY. PUT IT IT'S TOO
IT'S TO FOCUS ON RECENTLY
HOMELESS.
FOLKS BECAUSE YOU THINK THERE'S
A GOOD BANG FOR THE BUCK THERE
WHICH I I I I WOULD TEND TO
AGREE. I I THINK ONE OF THE
CHALLENGES WERE ALL GRAPPLING
WITH IS OF THE PERCENTAGE OF
FOLKS WHO ARE HOMELESS THERE'S
SUCH A LARGE PERCENTAGE OF
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS.
FOR WHOM WE SPENT AN AWFUL LOT
OF MONEY.
TO.
ECHO MISTER OBERNOLTE IS POINT
WE KNOW IF YOU'RE CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS ON THE STREETS IT MAY
COST US FORTY TO SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS A YEAR. BUT IF WE CAN
GET THEM TO SUPPORT OF HOUSING
WE COULD HAVE THAT NUMBER. A AND
BE MUCH MORE COST EFFICIENT
WITHOUT IN SUPPORT OF I THINK
WHAT I AM OR WE ARE ALTERNATE
RAP WITH THIS POLICYMAKERS IS
WHAT IS WHAT IS THAT RIGHT
BALANCE. AND MY COMMITTEE WE DID
AN ANALYSIS OF OF AB THIRTY ONE
SEVENTY ONE AND OF AND A FEW
THINGS THAT WE HAD SUGGESTED ARE
ONE. OF SPENDING MONEY ON THE
HOUSING FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM WHICH IS THE ONLY STATE
PROGRAM TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF
TRULY CHRONICALLY HOMELESS.
INDIVIDUALS THAT COHORT I JUST
REFERRED TO WHO WOULD OTHERWISE
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN AND OUT OF
EMERGENCY ROOMS AND AND JAIL.
AND AND JAIL FACILITIES IN
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES.
COST US AN AWFUL LOT MORE THAN
WE WOULD IF WE COULD FIGURE OUT
A WAY TO PUT A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEADS.
I ALSO IF YOU'RE UP TO ME I
THINK A LARGE PORTION OF THAT
MONEY EVEN THREE QUARTERS OF
THAT FUNDING SHOULD GO TO MOVING
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS.
INTO SUPPORT OF HOUSING IN A
VARIETY OF DIFFERENT WAYS PUMP
BUT THAT BEING SAID IF I'M OPEN
AND IT TO UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
FLEXIBILITY MEANS I THINK IT. I
THINK THE MORE INFORMATION WE
HAVE FROM THE BIG ELEVEN CITIES
ABOUT EXACTLY WHAT THE PLANS ARE
SO THAT YOUR.
SO THAT WE CAN WE CAN TEST THAT
BECAUSE I KNOW FOR EXAMPLE LOT
OF THE STATE WHAT POLICY
ADVOCATES.
HAVE SEEN MANY MANY BUDGETS
THROUGH MANY MANY POLITICIANS
AND HAVE SEEN SOME PROGRAMS WORK
IN SOME PROGRAMS NOT AND AND
THERE. THERE'S A DESIRE TO HAVE
TO SPEND MONEY WHERE WE KNOW THE
DATA SHOWS IT'S GOING TO HAVE AN
IMPACT AND YOU'RE PROPOSING.
THAT THERE ARE NEW WAYS FOR US
TO DO THAT WHICH VERY WELL COULD
IMPACT THIS BUT I THINK IF WE
KNOW THAT UP FRONT AND WE HAVE
SOME METRICS UP FRONT THAT'LL.
HELP MAKE EVERYONE FEEL MORE
COMFORTABLE ABOUT. ABOUT WHERE
THIS GOES FAIR POINT.
MANTIS
AB ABSOLUTELY THAT.
.
THE MAYOR OF THE TOWN.
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES OF
COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. TOTALLY AGREE AND
THAT IS THE BEST PRACTICE AND
THAT IS WHY. ONE POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLAR BOND WAS PASSED.
FOR A CHRONICALLY HOMELESS HOUSE
PERMANENT SUPPORTIVE HOUSING FOR
CHRONICALLY HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
AND THEN THE PROB I MEASURE H.
WAS TO PROVIDE THE SERVICES.
THAT. POPULATION WHILE SO USE IT
REPRESENTS AN INCREDIBLE
INVESTMENT AN ONGOING INVESTMENT
I THINK THAT'S WHY YOU HAVE THE
OP. FUNDING FOR.
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT
SAID AND ANY NUMBER OF IS THAT
BECAUSE THERE IS THAT SAME AS
WITH. A HOUSING FOR HEALTH AND
IN THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES.
WHAT WE ALSO?
POINT OUT IS THAT THAT IS
APPROXIMATELY THIRTY PERCENT OF
THE HOMELESS POPULATION IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT THE OTHER.
SIXTY SIX SEVENTY PERCENT OF THE
POPULATION. ARE THOSE PEOPLE
THAT ARE FALL IT BETTER IN THAT
ARE HOMELESS.
ARE NOT.
NECESSARY AND ARE NOT
CHRONICALLY MINT REGARDED AS
CHRONICALLY MENTALLY ILL. BUT
THE LONGER THEY ARE ON THE
STREETS THE LONGER THE LID
GREATER THE LIKELIHOOD THAT THEY
WILL BECOME THAT. PORTION OF THE
POPULATION THAT'S SO MUCH
COSTLY.
AND THAT.
NOW.
WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO NOT DO
ONE OR THE OTHER BUT TO DO BOTH
AND IT WE COULD TACKLE THIS TO
STABILIZE IN A WAY WHERE THEN.
WE WOULD BE ABLE TO.
MORE ACCURATELY IDENTIFY SORT
OF HOW MUCH GOES FOR CHRONICALLY
HOMELESS VERSUS THOSE THAT ARE.
THAT ARE SIMPLY HOMELESS BUT AT
ANY EVENT IT'S
SOMETHING WHERE THE INFLOW. HAS
TO BE STEM IF WE'RE GOING TO
MAKE ANY PROGRESS AND WHERE WE.
AS THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN
THE WORLD. CANNOT TURN AWAY.
THANK YOU MISS CAMBIADO.
I REALLY APPRECIATE THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I'M.
FRANKLY.
.
I DON'T HAVE ANY OF THAT.
ELEVEN LARGEST CITY IN MY
DISTRICT. SO I APPRECIATE YOU
GUYS COMING FORWARD AND SAYING
LOOK AT THIS IS WHAT WE THINK
SHOULD HAPPEN BUT I'M GONNA NEED
TO HEAR FROM MY CITIES THAT.
BETTERS GRAPPLING WITH THIS AND.
I'M STRUCK BY THE WHOLE IDEA
PREVENTION.
INTERVENTION OP BECAUSE THEY.
IT DIDN'T REALLY WHAT THAT WITH
THE PREVENTION INTERVENTION GETS
TO IS THE WHOLE ISSUE OF WE
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH UNITS.
AND THEY'RE NOT AFFORDABLE.
AND SO EIGHT THAT THAT'S BEEN IN
INTRACTABLE PROBLEM IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AS YOU KNOW ANYTIME
YOU START TALKING ABOUT BUILDING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR EVEN A
FACILITY FOR HOMELESS YOU GET
TREMENDOUS RESISTANCE FROM THE
COMMUNITY. AND I'VE BEEN WORKING
ON A REGIONAL BASIS TO TRY TO
JUST ON.
STEMS SOME OF THE.
SOME OF THE M.. HOMELESS.
.
HOLDS THAT THERE ARE AND JUST
BEING JUST TRYING TO GET OUT AND
TALK TO PEOPLE ABOUT ALLOWING.
UP DIFFERENT KINDS OF HOUSING IN
THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS ARE IS JUST
TERRIBLE I MEAN IT AT ITS NOBODY
WANTS.
ANYBODY NEAR THEM AND SO ON SO
THE DIFFICULT OF DOING THAT
PREVENTION INTERVENTION WORK IS
IS GOING TO BE THERE AND IT AND
IT'S TERRIBLY EXPENSIVE.
SO I'M STRUGGLING WITH HOW YOU
KNOW HOW IF YOU'RE GONNA GET
RESOURCES AND ITS NEW RESOURCES
HOW DO YOU SET UP THE
ACCOUNTABILITY HOW DO YOU SET UP
THE METRICS SO THAT. THEN EVEN
RURAL AND SMALLER COMMUNITIES
ARE UTILIZING THE SAME
METHODOLOGY OR THE SAME SYSTEM
OR SO THAT WERE ALL DOING THINGS
IN A WAY THAT REALLY IS GOING TO
REACH AN OUTCOME. SO THAT WE
DON'T PUT. TWO TWO BILLION HER A
BILLION DOLLARS OUT THE IN A
YEAR AND THEN WE'RE IN THE EXACT
SAME POSITION AND EVERYBODY
COMES BACK THEN THEY REALLY
THOUGHT THAT THAT WAS GOING TO
DO IT FOR WHAT HERE BUT WE
COULDN'T DO IT YOU KNOW I AM
SAYING.
SO WELL THAT I BUT I REALLY
APPRECIATE THIS DISCUSSION
BECAUSE I REALLY HADN'T FOCUSED
ON THE.
PREVENTION INTERVENTION PART OF
IT WHICH IS WHICH IS THAT THAT'S
A WHOLE ANALOGY OF PEOPLE.
PEOPLE ARE STANDING AT THE RIVER
AND THEY SEE BODIES FLOATING
DOWN IN THERE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHAT'S GOING ON THERE. GOING
AND PULLING THEM OUT IN THE
SUMMER DECIDES TO GO UPRIVER TO
FIND OUT HOW THEY'RE ENDING UP
IN THE FOR IN THE RIVER IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND THAT'S REALLY
WHAT THE PREVENTION IS ALL ABOUT
IS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. HOW DO
WE KEEP PEOPLE FROM FALLING INTO
HOMELESSNESS?
AND I'VE BEEN TALKING TO A LOT
OF PEOPLE AND THEY'RE THAT
CLOSE.
I HAD I HAD BOMB AND I KNOW THAT
PEOPLE ARE SICK OF ME TELLING
THIS TALE BUT I HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THE WOMAN WHO
TOLD ME SHE WAS SCARED
EMBARRASSED AND FINALLY ASHAMED.
BECAUSE HER RENTED GONE UP A
HUNDRED PERCENT IN FIVE YEARS.
AND SHE WAS TWO INCOME EARNERS
IN THEIR FAMILY AND THIS WAS IN
SALINAS AND SHE SAID. I'M
ASHAMED BECAUSE I'M AND WE MAY
END UP HOMELESS AND I MAY HAVE
TO TELL MY FAMILY AND THERE'S NO
OTHER ALTERNATIVE AND. THEY'RE
WORKING HOW DO YOU END UP
HOMELESS WHEN YOU'RE WORKING AND
NOT READ SO SO THE SITUATION IS
IS YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THERE
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE RIGHT. ONE
PAYCHECK AWAY ONE. ACCIDENT ONE
ILLNESS ONE.
YOU KNOW INCREASE IN IN THE
RENT AND SO WE GOT TO FIGURE OUT
HOW THAT WE HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE BIG PICTURE IS THAT IN
THAT I THINK THAT'S WHAT MISTER
OBERNOLTE WAS GETTING TOO AND I
AM A LITTLE FRUSTRATED BECAUSE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BEEN MY
NUMBER ONE ISSUE FOR THIRTY
YEARS AND IT HASN'T GOTTEN ANY
BETTER IN THE LAST THIRTY YEARS
AND SO.
APPRECIATE YOUR.
YOUR ENERGY AND YOUR.
HERE.
YOU KNOW PUTTING ON PAPER WE
THINK IS GOING TO WORK BECAUSE I
WANT TO SEE IT HAPPEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHOI.
OKAY LET ME ADD A FEW. OF MY
FRUSTRATIONS.
.
AND FROM LISTENING TO OF THE
PROBLEMS WE ALL KNOW THAT THAT
THAT IS A VERY.
A SERIOUS.
A STATE ISSUE.
I I FEEL LIKE A MORE THAN HALF
OF MY TIME HERE AT THE.
IN THE LEGISLATURE WE HEAR IS
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AFFORDABLE
HOSTING.
AND THAT WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO
DO IS.
.
IF WE PROVIDE THE ENOUGH MONEY
OR THE SOLUTION WOULD BE.
.
IN A FOUND.
BUT ALSO INTERESTING TO HEAR
THAT.
.
EMILY STUNNED BROKE SO. NOISE
NOT PROMESAS.
IT IS JUST THE IN.
THERE'S NO NOT MUCH BETTER
THERE'S A KNOCK KNOCK JUROR.
WE ARE TRYING TO.
AND MINIMIZE.
THE IT EVEN IT'S ALSO IRONIC
HERE AT THE STATE CAPITOL WE
TALK ABOUT THIS SO.
JUST ABOUT THE ON A DAILY BASIS
BUT THAT JUST ACROSS THE STREET
THE.
YOU SEE RIGHT THERE HOMELESS
PEOPLE. KNOW EVEN THOUGH YOU I'M
MIGHT HAVE.
REDUCE THAT NUMBER.
IT IS SO FULL OF SHAME FOR US
TO.
YOU KNOW TAKE IT AS A.
SERIOUS
OUR ISSUE OF THE STATE LOCAL
ISSUES.
AT THE EVEN THAT THE KEPT THEIR
CD WE CANNOT SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
ARE AYE I HAVE A MAYBE. I THINK
I THINK I CAN TALK HIM INTO MANY
DIFFERENT THINGS I THINK ARE.
WHEN WE HEAR PREVENTION AND
INTERVENTION COR LISTED ALL
KINDS OF GOOD WORDS.
IN ALL MY WAY OF LOOKING AT THE
PROBLEM IS SO. WE ARE TRYING TO.
A PROVIDE I COME UP WITH SOME
SOLUTIONS SO TO THE PROBLEM BUT
THE.
IS TO MORE THAN PREVENTION WHAT
INTERVENTION Y. SUCH A PROBLEM.
IS SUPPOSED TO STING AND THE
INCREASING.
NOT DECREASING I KNOW THIS IS A
NOT US IMPROVE.
ANSWER.
OF HOWEVER.
WHY DID IT BECOME THE YOU KNOW
HOMELESS?
WITH NO MONEY RIGHT.
WHY NO MONEY NO JOBS?
WHY NO JOBS?
BECAUSE OF THE ONGOING PROCURER
SO TOOL WE KNOW WHO MAY. ARE
HIRE THEM.
EVEN THOUGH WE WE DO SEE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE COST DOWN.
AS YOU ARE KNOWN A WILL
CALIFORNIA IS SO KNOWN AS A
NOTORIOUS.
BUSINESS REGULATIONS AND THE
BUSINESSES HER PACKING UP AND
LEAVING. LAST SO WHAT THE ABOUT
A DECADE OR SO NINE THOUSAND
SOMETHING BIG BUSINESSES HAVE
LEFT.
SO THOSE OF BUSINESS OF WHEN
THEY ARE IN A BUSINESS BIG
BUSINESS OF LEAVE WHAT THEY
LEAVE OUT WITH THE TOPS OF.
AND SO WHAT.
NO THOSE ARE THE DIRECTLY.
COORDINATED ISSUES.
AND A GOOD JOB SO WE NEED TO
CREATE THE AND WE NEED TO
FOSTER.
IT I FOR EXAMPLE. OUTPUT A
SECOND TIME OUR I INTRODUCED ARE
A BIT OF. A WHICH I NAMED SL Y.
COME BUSINESS OF BACK TO
CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU CREATE THIS YEAR IT
PASTOR REVENUE AND TAXATION
COMMITTEE YESTERDAY.
A IF YOU BRING BACK A.
YOUR JOB YOU YOUR BUSINESS TO
CALIFORNIA WITH A TWENTY ONE
MORE PEOPLE WILL GIVE YOU A
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE PERCENT.
BUT A TAX CREDIT.
AND OR IF YOU EAT EXISTING
BUSINESSES SO HERE IN CALIFORNIA
IF YOU EXPAND THE* MORE FULL
TIME EMPLOYEES WILL GIVE YOU A
TAX CREDIT.
WHAT I'M? I'VE BEEN TRYING TO DO
WAS TALK TO FOSTER I CANNOT AS
TO MINORITY MEMBER I NO I CANNOT
UNDO THE EXISTING. OUR
REGULATIONS.
SO WHAT I'M TRYING TO DO WAS SET
TO CREATE THE MORE JOBS.
YOU KNOW BY FOSTERING ON THE
BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT THAT THAT'S
WHAT I'VE BEEN DOING SO I THINK
APPLAUSE OF THE DEEP MORE
COMPREHENSIVE THINGS SO WE NEED
TO TALK ABOUT THE.
WHEN WE TRY TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM
THAT WE CREATE THAT PROBLEM.
BEGIN WITH.
LOOK THAT DUST OF FRUSTRATION
INSIDE.
OF ME.
OKAY THAT'S MY. DUFF VENTING MY
FRUSTRATION HERE'S MY QUESTION.
ONE OF YOU CITIES. FOR ALL.
ARE.
SOME FRANCISCO WERE LA OR
SACRAMENTO.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO. WORK A
CREATE OF PROFIT.
PUBLIC PARTNERSHIP.
OUR FOR STARVING THOUGH ON
HOMELESSNESS ISSUES THAT THERE
WAS SOMEONE. A BUSINESSMAN WHO
APPROACHED ME FROM A CHINA.
HE.
ONE HIS ARE LOOKING FOR A CITY
OR LOCAL GOVERNMENT TAP OR. WHAT
TONY?
THAT THE GIVING THEM AUTHORITY
AND THAT GIVING THE PARTNERSHIP
FOR.
.
IF HE WERE TO SOLVE ALL THE
PROBLEMS SO WE FEEL LESS THAN
THIRTY PERCENT OF THE GOVERNMENT
OR WOULD HAVE COST.
AND WITH THAT ARE I THINK THAT
ONE OF TWO CONDITIONS.
IS SELF.
HELPING THEM FIND THE ZONING
PLAYER.
.
THE FACILITIES AT THAT HOUSING
CAN BE PLACED.
AND THE BUILDING PROMISE WOULD
BE EXPEDITED.
AND THEN EDUCATION ISSUES HEALTH
ISSUES TO MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
OF WHATEVER EDUCATION ISSUE SO
THEY WERE. ARMED DEPARTMENT.
THE DEPARTMENT ALISA AND THEN
HELP THEM.
SO I THINK THIS IS SO IT GREEK
IDEA GOVERNMENT TRIED THAT CASE
TO HAVE TRIED AND TRIED THE IT
HAS NOT WORKED.
HAS ANYBODY APPROACH.
THAT THE PROBLEM THE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIP APPROACH IF YOU HAVE
NOT THE WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO
LISTEN AND TALK TO THE PERSON.
THAT AFFECTS ONE MAKING PROFITS
DOT BEFORE ON THE BACKS OF
HOMELESSNESS IS IS THE CORRECT
METHOD FOR THIS.
AND YOU TALK ABOUT THE.
EARLY SADISM.
JOBS OBVIOUSLY MINIMUM WAGE JOBS
IS NOT A FAVORITE AS A BIG ISSUE
CALIFORNIA TREE LA JOBS BUT
MINIMUM WAGE JOBS DON'T PAY RATE
WILL NOT BY YOU HOUSE.
SO I I THINK YOU KNOW THE BIG
GREAT PUBLIC PRIVATE
PARTNERSHIPS IN CERTAIN AREAS
BUT FOR HOMELESSNESS AYE AYES
YOU KNOW WHERE HE IS THE ONLY
THING OF IT WHEN YOU REALLY
THINK ABOUT IT. THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO COMBAT
HOMELESSNESS IS HROUGH FORM OF
PUBLIC PRIVATE PARTNERSHIP
BECAUSE THE COUNTIES THEMSELVES
GENERALLY.
DO NOT RUN THE PGA OR THE CITIES
DON'T ACTUALLY RUN THE PROGRAMS.
WE ACTUALLY WORK WITH.
MOSTLY NON PROFIT BUT THERE ARE
A FEW FOR PROFIT PROVIDERS WHO
HAVE THE EXPERTISE.
AND HOW TO.
AND HOW TO HELP THE POPULATION
THE WAY
IS ACTUALLY THE CAPACITY.
BUILD OF THE COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT I SUPPOSE COULD INCLUDE.
A FOR PROFIT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
THAT THAT DID THAT WORK. BUT
WITHOUT THE THE INFUSION OF
PUBLIC INVESTMENT.
WE HAVE NOTHING TO OFFER.
THE PRIVATE SECTOR IF YOU WILL
OR THE NONPROFIT SECTOR TO BE
ABLE TO DO ONE OF THE WORKS I
THINK THERE'S OF IP INTEREST IN
THE CONVERSATION.
OKAY YOU KNOW.
AT JUST WHY NOT NOW THERE COULD
BE A COOK THERE COULD BE A
KERNEL OF SOME THEIR.
.
THOUGHT WE WOULD BE INTERESTED
AS WELL AND WE'RE CURRENTLY
EXPLORING.
.
CREDIT TENANT LEASE FINANCING
MODEL.
IN WHICH THE PRIVATE SECTOR
COULD CONSTRUCT.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT COULD
THEN BE LEAST BACK.
BY THE COUNTY.
IN ORDER TO CUT CONSTRUCTION
COSTS AND THE AMOUNT OF TIME IT
TAKES TO BUILD HOUSING SO WE'RE
CURRENTLY LOOKING AT AT
ALTERNATIVE MODELS AND WOULD BE
HAPPY TO. HAVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH WITH ANYONE WHO'S GOT I
KNOW ALREADY HAPPY TO MAKE THAT
TO PREACH. AND AND AND NOT BASED
UPON OUR WHAT I'VE READ HERE IS
SUCH TRYING TO GET RID OF OUR.
NOW FAITH THE BASTER COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS ARE I MEAN AND TO
ME IT THIS HAS SO WRONG IN OUR
APPROACH TO SOMEONE'S CENTER.
NOW THE HOUSING FIRST OR WHAT
WOULD SOLVE ALL THE PROBLEMS SO
ONE ENTITY GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN
TRYING TO DO THAT THOUGH IT
WOULDN'T IT WILL IT DIDN'T WORK.
SO I THINK THAT THERE ARE E.
EITHER.
THE
DOUG LA EACH
A PRIVATE PUBLIC PARTNERSHIP OFF
FACE OF FAITH BASED A SMALL
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS SO FAR IT
HAS SO.
.
IT AT LEAST THAT THEY HELPED.
A IN COUNSELING FROM THE
BEGINNING IN A BEFORE THEY UP
RUN INTO A AT THEM MENTAL ISSUES
SO WHY WHITE MEN MENTAL. HEALTH
THE BECOME SUCH A ISSUE. AND I
WOULD GO CRAZY IF I DON'T HAVE
MONEY AND THE MY FAMILY WOULD
END UP ON THE STREET. AMID THE
METAL HALF THE WOULD DISAPPEAR
WHEN THEY'RE SO NO MONEY
A I CAN THEM MET MENTAL HEALTH
OR BE AFFECTED.
SO I I THINK WE NEED TO. WORK
WITH THE INSTEAD WITH GETTING
VETO BY A COMMITTEE BASED OF
BASED ORGANIZATION SO WE NEED TO
WORK WITH THEM.
IN A WRITTEN MANY WASTED BECAUSE
A GOVERNMENT THAT CANNOT SOLVE
ALL THE PROBLEMS BY HIRING AND
NUMBER OPAL AND NOT GOVERNMENT
EMPLOYEES.
THAT'S MY.
YOU KNOW TO SENSE REGULATORY
THIS POINT WILL OPEN UP FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT AND WE WOULD
NEVER HAVE TO GET BACK TO CITY
HALL FOR A COUNCIL MEETING HIS
HEAD OKAY THANK YOU MISTER MAYOR
PROPITIATE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND.
BUT IS VERY GOOD THANK YOU HAS
ALSO PHOTO NUMBER STICKERS SO
PLEASE KEEP YOUR COMMENTS BRIEF
IT IS OKAY SAY ME TOO. FED A LOT
OF DISCUSSION HERE SO ALONG THE
MORE MEMBERS HERE SO.
BEVERLY.
I APPRECIATED THAT THIRTY
SECONDS MISTAKE HERE. STEVE
CREWS ON BEHALF THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE AND MAYOR SAM LICCARDO I
KNOW HE WAS HERE A FEW WEEKS AGO
ALONG WITH.
MAYOR STEINBERG MAKING THE
ROUNDS IN SUPPORT OF THIS
FUNDING REQUEST.
IS THE THIRD LARGEST CITY IN
CALIFORNIA.
LARGEST IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
THE CITY OF SAN JOSE EXPERIENCE
IN HIS ITS FAIR SHARE OF
HOMELESSNESS OVER FIVE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS EXPERIENCE HOW MUCH
EACH DAY.
SO WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS REQUEST WE THINK AND WE
AGREE WITH SENATORS AB.
MAYOR STEINBERG IN TERMS OF THE
FLEXIBILITY THE FUNDING AND ALSO
ENSURING THAT WE WORK WITH OUR
OUR COUNTY PARTNERS.
ON THIS IN THIS EFFORT AND SO
AGAIN WE.
OUR STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
MISTER MAYOR YOU MISTER DRUCE.
HIGH AND ARMY COLONEL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES AND WE OWE THEM ARE
SUPPORTIVE IF AMENDED OF THE
PROPOSAL FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TEENS DEL BECAUSE WE BELIEVE
COUNTIES ARE PARTNERS WITH
CITIES ON ALL OF THIS.
AND IT'S INTERESTING THAT YOU
HAVE LA AND SAN FRANCISCO HERE
BECAUSE SAN FRANCISCO IS A CITY
AND COUNTY AND LA HAS ANIMAL YOU
WITH THEIR COUNTY THE CITY OF LA
HAS MEMO YOU WITH THEIR COUNTY.
TO PROVIDE THESE SERVICES AND SO
THEIR PARTNERSHIPS ARE WHAT MAKE
THEM SO SUCCESSFUL IN WHAT
THEY'RE DOING. SEES ACT HAS AND
A PROPOSAL WHICH WOULD BE TO PUT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO NO PLACE
LIKE HOME IF THERE'S A SURPLUS
AS WELL IS. BUILDING ON THEM
PUTTING MONEY INTO THE MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROGRAM BECAUSE
WE BELIEVE THE LONG TERM
SOLUTION IS IMPORTANT. BUT THE
EMERGENCY SHELTER PIECE IS
IMPORTANT TOO THERE'S A
CONTINUUM AND SO WE JUST DON'T
THINK THAT A BILLION DOLLARS
SHOULD GO TO CITIES TO DO
EMERGENCY SERVICES. WE FEEL THAT
THERE SHOULD BE A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN COUNTIES AND CITIES TO
GET ALL OF THIS DONE INTO THAT
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM VALUE.
NICHOLAS DELUDE A HERE WE HAVE
OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY SHAFT IN
SANTA ANA MAYOR MIGUEL PULIDO IN
STRONG SUPPORT I JUST TELL YOU A
WHAT'S GOING ON IN OAKLAND IS
ABSOLUTELY HEARTBREAKING. THREE
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND IN
DISCUSSING THIS IN YOUR
CONSIDERATIONS OF THANK YOU AND
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHARON REPORT
WITH THE CORPORATION FOR SUPPORT
OF HOUSING I WERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT.
AND SUPPORT BOTH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TINGS PROPOSAL
AS WELL AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER TWO.
I WE DO THINK THE LEGISLATURE
HAS A ROLE IN ENSURING A
BALANCED APPROACH AND OF FOR
FUNDING PROGRAMS THAT ARE.
PROVEN SOLUTIONS TO HOMELESSNESS
WHICH REALLY IS LONG TERM
HOUSING.
NOT JUST FOR PRODUCTION BUT
ALSO FOR RENTAL ASSISTANCE TO
GET PEOPLE OFF THE STREET AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND WITH
LANDLORD INCENTIVES. AND WITH
OPERATING SUBSIDIES
TO.
FUNDS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
PROJECTS IN THE PIPELINE TO MAKE
AFFORDABLE TO PEOPLE
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS ALL
THREE OF THOSE SPEAKERS.
REPRESENT CITIES WHO ARE DOING
THIS ALREADY THERE ARE INVESTING
HEAVILY AND AND A LONG TERM
HOUSING SOLUTIONS THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CITIES. THEIR
BIGGEST MISSING GAP IS PERMANENT
HOUSING FUNDING.
SO WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE SOME
INSURANCE ABOUT BAD IS GOING TO
BE WHAT'S FUNDED THANK YOU HOME.
I WOULD JUST MENTION REAL
QUICKLY STATES THAT HAVE REDUCE.
HOWEVER HOMELESSNESS FOR THEIR
MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
INCLUDING CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
PEOPLE.
HAVE SEEN MEASURABLE RESULTS WE
HAVE FORTY TWO PERCENT OF THE
NATION'S CHRONICALLY HOMELESS
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA THIRTY
EIGHT PERCENT OF THE NATION'S
HOME HOMELESS YOUTH POPULATION.
WE THINK THERE SHOULD BE SOME
ATTENTION PAID TO THOSE TWO
POPULATIONS THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS SUGGEST
RILEY CALIFORNIA CITIES I KNOW
YOU AS OUR BRIEF SO I ONLY HAVE
TEN POINTS TO MAKE. I'M JUST
KIDDING.
JEW THINGS I WOULD LIKE TO
HIGHLIGHT ONE THE FUNDS WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE I'M MORE
FUNDS AUGMENTS SERVICES OF
COUNTIES REALLY AREN'T PROVIDING
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
INTO.
THAT THE FUNDS WERE SEEKING A
WILL WILL GET ALL CITIES THAT
ARE TACKLING THIS ISSUE SO IT'S
NOT JUST THE BIG ELEVEN YOU KNOW
WE APPRECIATE THEIR LEADERSHIP.
THEM STRONG ADVOCATES BUT IT'S
FOR ALL CITIES THAT ARE THERE
TACKLE THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
THANK THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS.
HERE ON BEHALF MORE TOP HERE ON
BEHALF OF.
IN HIGH MAYOR TOM TAPE AND SAN
DIEGO MAYOR KEVIN FAULCONER WE
JOIN AYE OUR FELLOW AT BIG
ELEVEN MAYORS.
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
INITIATIVE
APPRECIATE THE TIME YOU'VE GIVEN
WITH US.
TODAY AND I I THINK JUST TO
FIND POINTS TO PUT ON AGREEING
WITH EVERYTHING THAT ASSEMBLY
BEEN SAID TODAY BUT ONE IN TERMS
OF FLEXIBILITY. FLEXIBILITY ALSO
MEANS.
AND.
UNDERSTANDING AND GIVING
FLEXIBILITY FOR ALL THE VARIOUS
AREAS OF THE STATE FOR EXAMPLE
SAN DIEGO HAS ONE OF THE LARGEST
VETERAN POT VETERAN HOMELESS
POPULATIONS.
AND SO WHAT WE OFFER TO VETERANS
IS GOING TO BE DIFFERENT THAN
PERHAPS WHAT'S OFTEN TO OFFERED
IN SAN FRANCISCO SO THAT'S
FLEXIBILITY. AND THEN SECONDLY I
KNOW WE ALL KNOW THIS BUT JUST
TO.
HIGHLIGHT THIS IS A MATCHING
PROGRAM SIR FOR EVERY DOLLAR
THAT WE'RE ASKING THE STATE TO
PUT IN. DAHLE ADD ONE DOLLAR
WOULD ALSO BE PUT IN BY THE
LOCALS AND SO WE THINK THAT'S A
GOOD BANG FOR YOUR BUCK AND VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE YOUR TIME THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CAN LOW'S
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YEAR THAT I REALLY
APPRECIATE TODAY'S DISCUSSION
AROUND HOMELESSNESS AND WHICH IS
NOW WOULD REALLY LIKE TO SEE
SOME DEDICATED RESOURCES TOWARDS
HOMELESS YOU. I'M IT IS A ON
SHELTER POPULATION FOR THE MOST
PART ABOUT EIGHTY THREE PERCENT
OF YOU CAN CALIFORNIA ARE AND
SHELTERED. LAST STATEWIDE SURVEY
IN TWO THOUSAND AND TEN I GET A
LITTLE BIT OLD BUT ONLY TWENTY
OF THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES AT
THAT TIME HAD SERVICES AT ANY
TIME FOR YOU. AND I COULD HAVE
BEEN ONE BAD. AND SO MORE
TALKING ABOUT CITY SPECIFIC WE
NEED TO TALK ABOUT RESOURCES IN
GENERAL FOR YOUTH EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS AND I'VE SEEN US
STATISTIC AROUND. FIFTY PERCENT
OF THE CHRONIC ADULTS EXPERIENCE
HOMELESSNESS WHEN THEY WERE
EIGHTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR SO IF WE
REALLY WANT TO GET UP AT
PREVENTION AND INTERVENTION.
TARGETING RESOURCES THAT YOUTH
IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
TYRONE BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF
HOUSING CALIFORNIA WE ARE ALSO
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SURPLUS GOING TO
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
HOMELESSNESS UNLIKE MANY OF THE
SPEAKERS HERE TODAY SAID ALL OF
THE DIFFERENT STRATEGIES NEED TO
BE EMPLOYED SO WE WANT TO SEE
THIS PROPOSAL BE REFLECTIVE OF.
NOT JUST EMERGENCY HOUSING BUT
ALSO RENTAL ASSISTANCE ALSO
PERMITS SPORT OF HOUSING ON TOP
OF THAT WE THINK ANY SPENDING
THAT COMES OUT THE BUDGET THIS
YEAR SHOULD ALSO INCLUDE.
SOME FUNDING FOR HOMELESS YOUTH
PROGRAMS THANK YOU YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ON LAWLER WITH
THE WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND ECHO THE COMMENTS
THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM HOUSING
CALIFORNIA JUST MADE A WE DO
WANT TOMAKE SURE THAT WE STRIKE
THE APPROPRIATE BALANCE BETWEEN
SHORT TERM EMERGENCY SOLUTIONS
AND. THE LONGER TERM SOLUTIONS
SUCH AS PERMITS PART OF HOUSING
AND RENTAL ASSISTANCE THAT WE
KNOW THAT THE ONLY WAY THAT
WE'RE EVER GOING TO REDUCE THE
RATE OF CONFLICT CHRONICLE MOST
IN CALIFORNIA THINKS IF YOU.
OR IN HIGGINS REPRESENT
CALIFORNIA HOUSING CONSORTIUM WE
ALSO SUPPORT A SIGNIFICANT ON
INVESTMENT BY THE STATE OF THE
SURPLUS AND AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND HOMELESS SERVICES.
I WANT TO ECHO THE COMMENTS OF
MY LAST TWO COLLEAGUES AND.
SUPPORT THE INCLUSION OF A
RANGE OF SERVICES INCLUDING
PERMANENT HOUSING THANK YOU BUT
YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS SYLVIA
SOLELY SHAUN BEHALF THE CITY OF
SANTA MONICA. WE BELIEVE THAT
CITIES ARE BEST POSITIONED TO
UNDERSTAND BUT LOCAL RESOURCES
ALREADY EXIST HOW BEST TO
UTILIZE THEM AND WHAT
DEFICIENCIES CURRENTLY EXIST IN
LOCAL RESPONSE EFFORTS. AS WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
PROPOSAL AND ASK FOR YOUR
FAVORABLE CONSIDERATION THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
OR TAKE THE PANEL FIRST
WELCOMING APPEAR TESTIFYING WITH
IT HAD SOME.
VERY INFORMATIVE.
DEBATE AND ALSO THANK CHAIRMAN
TING FOR COMING HERE THAT
INCLUDES OUR HEARING THANKS HAVE
A GREAT DAY